do you have a sense of what the
philosophy
that characterizes unix is the design
not just the initial but just carry
through the years
just being there being around it what's
the fundamental philosophy behind the
system
i think one aspect the fundamental
philosophy was to
provide an environment that made it easy
to write or easier
productive to write programs so it was
meant as a programmer environment it
wasn't meant
specifically as something to do some
other kind of job
for example it was used extensively for
word processing but it wasn't designed
as a word processing system it was used
extensively for lab control but it
wasn't designed for that it was used
extensively as a front end
for big other systems big dumb systems
but it wasn't designed for that
it was meant to be an environment where
it was really easy to write programs
so the programmers could be highly
productive and part of that was to be
a community and there's some observation
from dennis ritchie i think at the end
of the book that says that
that from his standpoint the real goal
was to
create a community where people could
work
as programmers on a system i think in
that sense
certainly for many many years it
succeeded quite well
at that and part of that is the
technical aspects of
because it made it really easy to write
programs people did write interesting
programs those programs tended to be
used by other programmers and so it was
kind of a virtuous circle
of more and more stuff coming out that
was really
good for programmers and you're part of
that community of programmers
so what was it like writing programs on
that early
unix it was a blast it really was
you know i like to program i'm not a
terribly good programmer
but it was a lot of fun to write code
and in the early days there was an
enormous amount of what you would
today i suppose called low-hanging fruit
people hadn't done things
before and this was this new environment
and
the the whole combination of nice tools
very responsive system and tremendous
colleagues
made it possible to write code you could
have an idea
in the morning you could do it you know
an experiment with it you could have
something limping along
that night or the next day and people
would react to it and they would say
oh that's wonderful but you're really
screwed up here
and and the feedback loop was then very
very short and tight
and so a lot of things got developed
fairly quickly
that um in many cases still exist today
and i think that was part of what made
it fun because programming
itself is fun it's puzzle solving in a
variety of ways but i think
it's even more fun when you do something
that somebody else then
uses even if they whine about it not
working the fact that they used it
is is part of the reward mechanism and
what was the method of
interaction the communication when you
that feedback loop
i mean this is before the internet
certainly before the internet um
it was mostly physical right there you
know somebody would come into your
office and say something
so these places are all close by like
offices are nearby so they're really
lively into interaction
yeah yeah no bell labs was fundamentally
one giant building
and most of the people were involved in
this unique stuff were in two or three
quarters and there was a room
oh how big was it probably
call it 50 feet by 50 make up a number
of that
which had some access to computers there
as well as
in offices and people hung out there and
it had a coffee machine
and so there was a it was mostly very
physical we did use email of course
um and but it was fundamentally all
for a long time all on one machine so
there was no need for internet
it's fascinating to think about what
computing would be today without bell
labs
it seems so many the people being in the
vicinity of each other
sort of getting that quick feedback
working together so many brilliant
people
it i don't know where else that could
have existed in the world i've been
given
how that came together what yeah
how does that make you feel that that's
that little
element of history well i think that's
very nice but
in a sense it's survivor bias and if it
hadn't happened at bell labs there were
other
places that were doing really
interesting work as well xerox park is
perhaps the most obvious one xerox part
contribute enormous amount of good
material um and many of the things we
take for granted today
in the same way came from xerox park
experience i don't think they
capitalized in the long run as much
their parent company was perhaps not as
lucky in
capitalizing on this who knows but that
would
that's certainly another place where
there was a tremendous amount
of uh influence there were a lot of good
university activities mit was
obviously no slouch in this kind of
thing and
others as well um so unix
turned out to be open source because of
the various ways that att operated and
sort of
had to um it was the focus was on
telephones
so i think that's a mischaracterization
in a sense
it absolutely was not open source it was
very definitely proprietary licensed but
it was licensed freely to universities
in source code form
for many years and because of that
generations
of university students and their faculty
people
grew up knowing about unix and
there was enough expertise in the
community that it then became possible
for people to kind of go off in their
own direction and build something that
looked unix-like
the berkeley version of unix started
with that licensed code and gradually
picked up enough of its own
code contributions notably from people
like bill joy
that eventually it was able to become
completely free of
any atm t code now there was an enormous
amount of
legal jockeying around this that in the
late
early to late 80s early 90s something
like that
um and then um
not some i guess the open source
movement might have started when
richard stallman started to think about
this in the late 80s and by 1991
when torvalds decided he was going to do
a
unix-like operating system there was
enough expertise that
in the community that first he had a
target he could see
what to do because the kind of the unix
system call interface and the tools and
so on were there
and so he was able to build an operating
system that
at this point when you say unix in many
cases what you're really thinking is
linux
linux yeah but it's it's funny that from
my
distant perception i felt that unix was
open source
without actually knowing it but what
you're really saying it was just uh
freely licensed so it was freely
licensed so it felt
open source and because universities are
not trying to make money so there
it felt open source in a sense that you
can get access if you wanted right and
and a very very very large number of
universities had the license and they
were able to talk to all the other
universities who had the license
and so technically not open technically
belonging to t
pragmatically pretty open and so there's
a ripple effect that all
the faculty and the students then all
grew up and then
they went throughout the world and uh
permeate in that kind of way so what
kind of features do you think make for a
good operating system
if you take the lessons of uh unix you
said
you know make it easy for programmers
like
that seems to be an important one
but also unix turned out to be
exceptionally robust and efficient
right so is that an accident when you
focus on the programmer or is that a
natural
outcome i think part of the reason for
efficiency was that it began
on extremely modest hardware very very
very tiny and so you couldn't get
carried away you couldn't do
a lot of complicated things because
you just didn't have the resources
either processor speed or
memory and so that enforced a certain uh
minimality of mechanisms and maybe a
search for generalizations
so that you would find one mechanism
that served for a lot of different
things rather than having lots of
different special cases
i think the file system in unix is a
good example of that
file system interface in its fundamental
form is extremely straightforward
and that means that you can write code
um very very effectively
for the file system and then one of
those id one of those
generalizations is that gee that file
system interface works for all kinds of
other things as well
and so in particular the idea of reading
and writing to devices
is the same as reading and writing to a
disk that has a file system
and then that gets carried further in
other parts the world processes
become in effect files in a file system
um and the plan 9 operating system which
came along i guess in the late 80s or
something like that
took a lot of those ideas from the
original unix and tried to
push the generalization even further so
that in plan nine a lot of different
resources
are file systems they all share that
interface so that would be one example
um we're finding the right model of how
to do something
means that an awful lot of things become
simpler and it means therefore that more
people can do useful
interesting things with them without
having to think as hard about it
you